all right Tyrell yes sir torello where'd
you grow up where are you from
originally uh I was born in Inglewood
California but I was raised all over
California San Bernardino Riverside uh
but I went to college in San Diego and
went to high school in San Diego so
that's my home
and you've been working as a uh a male
stripper in Las Vegas melon and Tanner
in Las Vegas for the last four years
tell me about that it's gonna be
interesting I love it man uh the way I
got into it actually
um a partner of mine was telling me to
join for about a year straight and I
always decline I'm like no I'm good I
got a good job
and one day I just quit
um it was one of those situations uh I
was like [ __ ] you [ __ ] you I'm out of
here that same day I went and tried out
and auditioned had no idea what I was
doing or experience
um and the song I danced to was the uh
was Chris Brown Take You Down
Hit the Floor belly rolled got up and
and left two weeks later they called me
back can you start the next day and I'm
here now
you like it I love it you know it's
definitely something that's uh changed
my life it's put me in um
and and in situations to where I can
Thrive um I feel like I have a name and
a voice and I feel like I'm somebody now
you make good money
I do okay I can't complain about it you
know so it's you you have you have your
dry spells but for the most part I do
pretty well for myself and you do you
you work in a club you also do private
parties I do those are my favorite
those are my favorite tell me about the
private parties man they they can range
from
one woman to 20 women you know a lot of
times women just want to spend time with
you hang out with you rub on you
sometimes I just want to enjoy your
company I just did a prior party last
week
and it was a bachelorette party
full new swinging everywhere women
man it was it was it was wild it was
wild it was wild
in the club the club you work in is an
African-American club right yes it is
all black and uh tell me about the women
that come in that club man the women uh
age range from 18 to 81. I love the
older women
um they're they're wild they're wild
these are all black girls or they're
mixed no you get a you get a mix of all
type of women you know from all over the
world which is the best because you get
a uh a variety as I like to say but you
know I love I love the women that come
in they're very supportive uh they're
crazy they try to pull your pants down
they're trying to kiss on you they
throwing drinks on you man it's it's
wild especially Our Queen of the Night
is a
is the spectrum of the night one woman
it's about six seven of us and we're
just showing her a good time
I'm talking dancing
uh I mean everything's in her face she's
trying to pull stuff down
oh man is in the crowd that you'll pick
out
yeah so Queen of the Night is something
that JC developed
um during the show that
women a woman can come on stage sit down
and be treated like a queen
we're a dance owner we're talking to her
we're making her feel good kissing on
her rubbing on her and just giving her
experience that she doesn't get at home
which is a
which is really important
what have you learned about women
um that they're just they're just like
us if not worse tell you the truth I
think women are a lot more um I don't
think they have a cap when it comes to
entertainment purposes as men we always
have to
you know throw the money and relax with
women man they go above Beyond
especially if if they're uh getting
married
that that allows who ra is really really
important to him
and something you want to take advantage
of for sure
a lot of the women that uh will go to
these clubs or or even the private
events that are married yeah yeah yeah
foreign relationships yeah and that
it definitely um
opened your eyes
makes you not want to get married
especially when you got millions and
thousands of women coming to Las Vegas
to to spend money and and get [ __ ] and
and just cuddle with another man you
know
it it's a little sad sometimes but I
profit off of it so I can't complain too
much about it
you personally you have a girlfriend
I do
so how does this career of yours
interfere or how does your personal
relationship live with with that
lifestyle uh it's definitely difficult
it's not an easy process
it's a learning curve and I think
transparent transparency is is
everything
um being open and honest about what
you're doing where you're going
uh how much money you're making things
of that nature uh goes a long way so
it's never easy in the beginning but as
long as you're able to communicate and
you know do right by her in so many
words and I think I think you'd be all
right a lot of the female
dancers strippers or whatever you want
to call them have told me that you know
they're gonna they're getting offers all
the time from guys that want to take
them yeah out of the club you get the
same kind of stuff yeah yeah I do I mean
I just went on a trip to Hawaii probably
like a month or two ago you know I'm a
sugar mama
uh flew me out there and it was
something I had to explain to her like
hey this is what's going on this was
happening I'll be back in a few days
and you're gonna have to deal with it or
or leave me you know there's nothing I'm
not going to change myself to
please you because at the end of the day
I have to live my own life
and what you eat don't make me [ __ ] and
you know vice versa so
it's it's all it's all just a
it's all just a big
big game at the end of the day you know
how is it impacted your self-worth your
self-esteem doing this and in what ways
I mean do you feel
like you're more a more attractive man
now because you've been doing this yeah
I've always I've always felt like I was
attractive male but I don't think I've
always had the confidence I have now I
think my confidence these days are
um through the roof and I don't want to
call myself cocky but you you you get to
a point to where uh you just know you're
that guy you know and you don't want to
put it on anybody you just you just you
just exert it it's just who you are it's
who you become and my confidence level
has definitely um gone through the roof
there's like no woman I I feel like I
can't have
and you know that that comes with the
territory it's like it's the mindset
that you need to have in this game
because otherwise you're going to look
like
you don't know what you're doing and
that's not what you want this is
probably a great job for a guy who lacks
confidence right if he could just get
over the yeah I feel like if you can get
over that hump because it's a it's a
it's a scary job man being a male
entertainer you know you're you're on
stage there's 300 women looking at you
and you don't know what they're thinking
but at the end of the day that shouldn't
matter
um as long as you have confidence in
yourself you can go out there and get no
money no screams but as long as you have
that same confidence you know as soon as
you walk on stage when you walk off
man the sky's the limit and that's one
thing I've learned as long as you're
confident in yourself everything else
will take care of itself
I'm 28 I'll be 29 January 11th oh you're
still young yeah but uh do you have any
regrets in your life like if if you had
your lecture to live all over again what
would you have done differently
man that's a that's a question would you
have done this earlier
I think
I think
well funny story because as a kid you
know like Middle School we used to go to
these parties and we used to like freak
dance and and everything and you know
dance on girls in Middle School
so I think if I knew that I was going to
do this I wouldn't have been so shy you
know in my early years of life I think I
would have been a little bit more
outgoing
um I would have been a little bit more
forthcoming
um
but I don't I don't have any regrets I
like where I'm at in life and it's
I like where I'm at in life man any
decision I made in the past was made for
a reason and I'm here right now for a
reason
you went to college I did I went to
Palomar College in uh San Marcos San
Diego did you have dreams of doing
something other than other than
stripping yeah I mean of course I want
to go to NFL I I love cooking I want to
be like a world famous chef uh I have
family in New Orleans that I got that
from my mom my grandma aunties but I
definitely wanted to be like one of
those Gordon Ramsay guy fiery type of
guys you know I just wanted to
people to taste my food and and just be
happy I think food is happiness
yeah I can still do that but I think
um right now I'm so focused on um
becoming as great as I can in this game
for as long as I can
that I get distracted sometimes but you
know
I think I just have to put in the time
and do it and with social media you have
to record everything and videotape
yourself all the time and I've never
been that guy to record myself in in and
edit content and things like that but
we'll see where it goes I just had a son
so what's the wildest offer you've had
as far as like doing power parties yeah
so I'm I'm gonna say this
um
there's no male entertainers in the
world who hasn't done parties for gay
men
and I'm one of them
and I've gotten offers from like
from from gay men to fly me out to
Chicago to do a a party for him and you
know butt naked and
you know and obviously I declined those
offers but there are some uh gay parties
that I do do for like friends and stuff
but I mean I think the wildest one I've
done was was this past weekend man it
was I I walked out that room butt naked
dick out ass out women went crazy they
want
almost have you ever seen a dancing
dancing teddy bear
no no basically it's a guy who walks
around the room for women has a teddy
bear
uh mascot helmet on is walks around and
all the women are like sucking his dick
and just partying like a bachelorette
party
it almost got that crazy but
the one was getting married the next day
they were recording I didn't want to be
embarrassed
or put in trouble
but you know I've had I've had women uh
I've had I've caught women trying to
drug me
um I've caught women stealing
uh
the money that they throw on the ground
they'll probably pick it back up and try
to put it back in their pocket but the
one of the craziest one was when I found
a woman trying to drug me I walked in
the bathroom I walked in the bar and she
was dumping a pill in my cup that she
was coming to bring me and I didn't even
do the party I just left I was like
y'all gotta mute [ __ ] up I'm not doing
this party getting my money and let me
go it was it was a huge deal
I never told anybody about that but that
sounds similar to women's yeah we we go
through we go through the same thing
that that women go through you know
because not all we're not
I think women get it misconstrued uh
like when we go do pirate parties we're
always looking to have sex with the
women at the party and that's not always
the case you know we want to be
professional as well we want to be
treated as as such
and I think women get offended sometimes
because they feel uh
uh
like it's supposed to happen but you
know we're morals we have values too as
men we don't [ __ ] everything
walking this Earth
and
the fact that I have values about myself
makes women uncomfortable sometimes
especially in private party settings hey
um I got an extra 100 bucks for you if
you want to you know
come in a room with me for 10 minutes 20
minutes
now
in the beginning of my my entertainment
career
I I took that hundred dollars for sure
I what you want to pay me to please me
how can I say no
but uh
you know you you tend to mature in the
game and realize that that doesn't
really get you
anything are you doing a selling your
soul
um
but
other than that
most of my parties are pretty legit and
uh I may I make good money doing them
thousands thousands of dollars doing
them so I can't complain that one bit
and when you like let's say let's say
you were single uh-huh and there were
women out there and not in the clubs but
in the in the regular world what advice
would you give to a guy who
like what have you learned from doing
this job that a guy outside of this
lifestyle
benefit from it's not as easy as you
think
yeah but in terms of like relationships
and what you've learned about women
um
that women just want to feel secure man
women want to feel like you're for them
and you know respected at the end of the
day
I think as long as you're able you're
able to communicate with your
significant other
and you guys are on the same page and
you bring it home the money
um there shouldn't be a problem and if
there is
settle it then and there
and don't downplay yourself to try to
make somebody else happy because at the
end of the day you're gonna make
yourself unhappy you know so stay ten
toes down man and and be true to to
yourself you know that's that's what I
would say was your family think of you
doing this they they love it they love
it they you know I've been able to
you know being a documentary with my
bosses and you know met so many people
and you know it's funny because my
cousin
my cousin sometimes called me like hey
man
I just talked to these women at the
hospital and they was like they was at
Blackmagic live this weekend they it's
like oh four players like that's my
cousin it's like like low-key famous in
a sense but they just love it you know
I'm not in jail I'm not gang banging I'm
not in the streets doing anything I'm
I'm bringing light to women's life
you know by taking my shirt off and
doing a few Body Rolls here and there
and smiling and just making them feel
safe and and and at at ease and at peace
and you know that's that's an amazing
trait to have you know women
I I don't just want to say women but
people go through [ __ ] on the everyday
in every day you know at home husbands
cheating on them kids or disrespectful
job and [ __ ] come to Vegas from the
black magic man come get some of this
chocolate you'll forget about all that
how do black women differ from white
women or other races what have you
learned in the clubs
I think that
the the white women are so in awe
because they're so used to the
excuse me to the uh the Magic Mike
Persona you know breakdance bop bop bop
and then they're done but when you come
to you know Blackmagic live or
you know any black strip club you're
gonna you're gonna feel culture you're
gonna feel energy you know it's going to
be sweaty it's going to be oils
everywhere the same dress you walked in
the club with it's not the same dress
you're gonna walk out with because this
is gonna be oil sweat it's just so much
more exciting like it's
but the black women are a lot more
accepting
um they're more understanding
and they know how to have a good time
not saying that you know
the white women and the Spanish women
don't but the black women they they know
what's up they know the culture they
know where we come from you know our
traumas and us as black men being on the
stage is like
it's amazing to them because they want
to honor us as as black kings as black
men you know so I think black women
definitely appreciate us a little more
even though white women love us I feel
like the black woman appreciates us a
handsome
young talented
man that smells good and can dance and
can move so
I would say that that's great what uh
what would you say Terrell's the most
important thing you've learned in your
life
to be patient man
I think patience is
a value that
[Music]
um
a lot of people look over especially I
wouldn't say especially but if you're in
this game everybody thinks like you can
just go on stage and do this and do that
and become this big household name and
it took me a couple years to just come
into my own you know
um you you sit back and you you watch
these your peers you know they're making
hundreds and hundreds of dollars a night
you're making 50 bucks here 20 bucks
here but you can't
compare yourself
to those people who've done it before
you've got to be patient wait your turn
you know and continue to put the work in
quietly
and What's Done in the Dark will
definitely come to the light so I think
just being patient
um
and and knowing your your self-worth
value is is everything being patient and
and knowing yourself not trying to be
like anybody else not trying to be like
the next man but affecting yourself
knowing yourself growing with yourself
and just having confidence in yourself
man
all right Terrell thank you so much for
sharing your story yes sir wish you the
best of luck out there thank you make
some money